so a weird thing happened uh about two
weeks ago I was on Instagram I suddenly
unpopped this picture
and it was you with a friend of mine
Cristiano Ronaldo the the Football
Genius greatest player to ever play the
game as far as I'm concerned and you'd
need to see it uh just privately
and he was saying how great it was that
he'd met you and you'd gone there and
all hell broke this he was bombarded
with people saying this is outrageous
Legend over Legacy finished none of
which would have bothered him because
he's heard all this kind of thing before
but the Venom of it was from certain
quarters was so pathetic it seemed to me
so first of all
what were you doing with Cristiano why
why were you there well he invited me to
come and see him and um he had had some
a trouble in his life a few months ago
and a friend of his sent him some of my
videos and he said he had watched those
and then he read my book one of my books
and found them very helpful and he
wanted to talk so I went out to his
house and we talked for about two hours
and he showed me all his equipment for
keeping himself in Tip-Top condition and
we talked a bit about his companies and
but mostly we talked about what he
wanted in the future and some of the
obstacles that he's facing while
pursuing that and so we had a strategic
conversation I would say for for about
on those topics for about 90 minutes
were you in a way were you that the Ted
lasso figure in his life well that's
what it felt he didn't realize he was
missing yeah well I think maybe he did
realize that he was missing it because
he seemed to have found it to some
degree in those lectures and so and I
was I I always like to hear not only
what people are up to but what they want
and I one of the things I loved about my
clinical practice which was very much
predicated on this like well you're
miserable let's say not to say that he
was because he has a good life in many
ways but
if you could Envision a path forward out
of your misery let's say to somewhere
better what would that look like and
it's not a question people ask
themselves with enough depth and then
having developed that vision
what are the strategies that might be
put in place to make that more likely
and again not in a manipulative way but
if you had to conduct yourself in the
proper manner to bring about this
desirable end or at least to move
towards it how would you how would you
organize your behavior when someone like
Cristiano who you know we know what the
personal problem was he'd lost a baby he
and his partner was incredibly sad for
him and professionally after that a lot
of turmoil as to whether he was going to
stay at his club and so on and so on
um it seemed to me talking to him in the
last couple of days after he saw you
he's in a much better place actually
that's what happens when you hang out
with reprobate like yes but really
interesting to me that so you got and
you and he both got criticized for just
seeing each other
um but actually it was clearly very
helpful too well I hope so that would be
lovely if it was true
it's a weird position isn't it there's
you Dr Jordan Peterson this guy that
comes out of Canada lecturing students
and then you're at the home of the
greatest football player of all time and
you'll genuinely helping him I mean
Ronaldo is known as one of the most
mentally strong athletes has ever been
yeah right not just physically but
mentally strong and yet he needed
someone like you to help him I find that
really fascinating well I don't know if
he needed me because he's a pretty
competent guy but but you know you can
always and this is something that very
competent people do you can always
improve on edge you know and so his life
is very well put together and he had
some trouble but people do but we talked
a lot about what he wanted how he wanted
his career to end in in the most
graceful possible Manner and how that
might be optimized and so I hope you
told him very well to sign for Arsenal
in the January transfer window did you
Jordan no I didn't give him I don't give
I try not to give people advice I mean
I'm curious on that because he's
obviously reaching not not the end of
his career by any means he's still the
world-class player and he's incredibly
fit so he could play for another three
four years perhaps but what is an end
game for someone who's achieved
everything in the game yeah well it
that's a good question it's hard for
people who who have had a stellar career
especially one that's to some degree
predicated on youth to figure out what
to do with the rest of their life now
he's well set up because he's a very
canny businessman and he has a young
family and he has lots of friends and as
far as I could tell on that front he's
situated himself extremely intelligently
so I think it looks to me like the
transition for him is going to be quite
smooth so but that's a testament to his
wisdom because he made sure that his
life was
was was founded on more than one
dimension of of attainment and that was
very wise
does it make you feel good that even
people like him can find great Solace
from watching your lectures
well all that makes me feel good I mean
I do think that this is part of the
reason I keep going on these lecture
tours is that it seems to be doing
people good so